we have a voicemail number two one nine
two david p i figure since it's my
birthday today
we'll do a little bit more of a
lighthearted voicemail take a listen to
this hi david my name is athelia i'm a
new viewer and i would like to know how
much time you spend on your hair always
looks so nice and i just figured that
take some time yeah thank you it really
doesn't take much time at all i use a
product called khru fiber men's crew
fiber or something like that it's sort
of like a paste of sorts and i get out
of the shower i put a little bit on my
hands I basically run it through my hair
I comb it and then nothing else is
needed it just dries and that's it I've
noticed from watching old clips of the
show that your hair style has changed
quite a bit over the years it has indeed
ya know it's evolved and it's it's an
evolving process it's an iterative
process I would say and we are where we
are now in great part because if men's
crew fiber and I get nothing from them
in fact it's it's kind of an expensive
product I think it's like 11 or 12 bucks
for a little 3 ounce thing although that
lasts a while you know well worth it cuz
you're in compliments I think it's
absolutely well worth it yeah and I
would love it for them to sponsor the
show I mean if there's any bigger
testament to the quality of the product
it's that it's been able to tame my
completely unruly and out-of-control
hair David sells out to big hair
products big hair has taken control of
the show literally and figuratively in
the business sense alright on the bonus
show today why do I dislike my birthday
I will address that we will also talk
about Alex Jones on the Joe Rogan
podcast not usually the type of thing I
would talk about but it was absolutely
hilarious so david pakman.com slash
membership to sign up remember the
birthday membership special is on the
coupon code is 33 today 3-3 today all
one word all lowercase because it is my
33rd birthday and i'm trying to take
attention away from it by having a
really great day for new members so take
advantage and we will talk to you on the
bonus show